[Musique]
alors un jour j'apprends que paris
première va arrêter rive droite rive
gauche
les missions au quotidien dit pourquoi
voulait arrêter cette émission ils
disent parce que nous on est une chaîne
privée on n'a pas à faire l'émission
culturelle si france 2 france 3 veut la
faire à qui le fasse j'ai appelé france
2 j'ai appelé france 3 ils m'ont dit non
non non vous pas d'émissions culturelles
surtout pas attendu pour toi de ne pas
faire ça alors là bon un personne ne
voulait vraie droite rive gauche une
patron de paris première me dit écoute
thierry on te propose de faire une hebdo
siné hebdo j'avais déjà eu ça s'appelle
tous nous on en parle je vais pas en
faire 2 et là arrive l'idée de faire un
dîner chez moi 93 faubourg saint-honoré
jeudi à la chaîne avait coûté voilà moi
j'ai cette idée
c'est ça ou rien at me dit c'est pas la
peine de s'énerver c'est une super idée
tu vas le faire et là pendant quatre ans
j'ai vécu avec des rails au plafond pour
accrocher les lumières et avec des
équipes qui arrivent et le lundi matin
chez moi pour ploguer l'appartement
c'était incroyable ma femme fait divorce
et c'est arrivé d'ailleurs alors ce qui
a fait le succès de 93 au lourd c'est
que c'était vraiment chez moi
toutes les tentatives qui ont été faites
de faire des dîners sur des plateaux n'a
jamais marché
je crois que les gens ont apprécié
vraiment il s'est vraiment chez toi ici
bah oui c'est chez moi donc ça ça
donnait une légitimité au dîner qui
étaient indépassables ans la soirée se
passer en cas de temps y'avait l'arrivée
dans la rue et l'ascenseur de
l'ascenseur il y avait des micros des
caméras tout ce qu'ils disent est
enregistrée du jean alias connard kel
away vraiment
après ils arrivent et on allait dans la
cuisine la cuisine y avait les plus
grands chefs de paris moi je m'en
rendais pas compte en fait puisque j'y
connais rien mais il y avait vraiment
des chefs incroyablement connu qui
étaient là qui venaient avec leur
bouffer leurs vins donc c'était plutôt
bien en prenaient l'apéritif dans la
cuisine
ensuite on allait au salon ont dîné et
pour finir une partie musicale
toujours évidemment plus étonnant
possible et les gens reprenaient
l'ascenseur et dans l'ascenseur faisait
sans le savoir
le bilan de la soirée on s'est dit
qu'est ce qui les comble quand même à
résister vraiment drôle et puis
l'émission avait un look incroyable
parce que sur la table j'avais mis des
bougeoirs ça faisait très barry lyndon
série d'émissions qui était quand même
éclairé à la bougie
le dîner était monté évidemment vont
garder pas tout et entre chaque séquence
il y avait des fondus au noir ça donnait
un côté très chic très cinématographique
le champagne et le vin aidant évidemment
les gens racontaient absolument
n'importe quoi à bout d'un moment il
avait oublié
ils s'étaient tous une émission de
télévision absolument délirant et moi
j'étais dans l'attitude inverse du talk
show dans un talk show je dois être au
filet il ya les faire parler les gens
tous là j'étais au fond du court là je
vois un pétard comme ça tu es bon tu
construis mon but tard j'ai mon verre de
vin et dans l'oreillette on me disait là
la tension baisse un peu c'est pas grave
la tension baisse un peu je disais une
connerie
essart allumer le feu c'était comme
mettre du bois dans une cheminée
en plus ce qu'ils étaient super si je
préparais rien moi qui travaille
beaucoup pour préparer mes interviews là
le principe comme c'était un dîner je
n'avais pas à préparer que tu avais pas
vraiment d'interviews factuel à faire
donc le mec arrive et gisait qu'est ce
tu fais toi en ce moment à mettez pas au
courant mais sinon mais sur un fil
mercredi alors c'est quoi ton film à mon
film c'est ça c'est ça
et voilà la promo été fait donc la promo
passait vraiment comme une lettre à la
poste et même pas besoin de faire la
promo et ensuite une fois tout est
terminé
bon allez au mathis qu'était le bar à la
mode à l'époque et on continue avec les
invités de musiciens je lâche 3 heures
du matin la bonne époque
alors évidemment ce qu'il faut regarder
dans 93 faubourg saint-honoré
c'est darmon et berry c'est à dire que
gérard darmon raconte une blague à
claude berri et on voit claude berri qui
était à l'époque déjà assez malade car
moment son visage quand il comprend la
blague c'est un vrai bonheur à la blague
est très bonne je vous la conseille et
aussi pierre palmade qu'elle est tombée
amoureuse du fils de celle là je vous le
conseille aussi il y avait un concours
pour séduire marjolaine et marjolaine
héroïne de télé réalité qui étaient là
et tous les mecs de la table voulait la
séduire et le meilleur c'était le père
de marion maréchal quitter
c'est lui qui avait gagné le concours
d'air et voilà il ya final vous regardez
le final musical de l'émission brésil
avec salomé des bayas et puis toute une
bande de brésiliens autour de la table
c'était vraiment énorme
et puis et puis christophe christophe
qui est venue un soir qui a dîné avec
louis l'a pas dit grand chose et après
il s'est mis au piano il a fait les mots
bleus
l'énième version démo bleus et c'était
inoubliable
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inhabituel abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux